everybody in this movies a mom the first
thing that happens is 5:00 in the
mornings like how'd you baby sleep how
was the night like that's the first
thing you asked how are the kids
hi honey can I get a hug I think at any
given time when you walk up to where our
cast chairs are we're all video chatting
our children such good mom but make no
mistake this is a very adult movie the
guy who wrote this also wrote the three
hangover movie so what can we expect
basically the same sort of vile language
it's not a family film reel is the
single working mom juggling two kids and
a career in real life she and Ashton
have just one daughter so far so I'm
wondering like does that make you think
about maybe a sibling oh for sure I mean
listen I'm not no I'm not pregnant
oh my god this is like this is sure that
rumors start um absolutely I do want to
have more kids one day for sure yes she
Kristen Bell and Kathryn Hahn go wild
going to war against perfect alpha moms
Christina Applegate Jada pinkett-smith
and bridesmaids co-writer Andy mamola
the lucky guy in the middle is NFL star
JJ why Milas football love and hubby
completely fanboy doubt he came to set
was he like more Justin seeing you that
day or JJ oh how dare you
of course JJ it's not even a question
what brings out the so-called bad mom in
you I'm on a schedule and things don't
always add to that schedule I have to
remind myself it's not like I can't be
like honey it's in the calendar it's
bedtime
mom night and I'm like forget it
you